president joe biden's border crisis not
going away as over 7 000 migrants travel
to del rio texas and are waiting near
that bridge waiting to be apprehended
after they've crossed into the united
states
this as department of homeland security
reveals migrant encounters in august
once again topped two hundred thousand
including more than eighteen thousand
unaccompanied children and border patrol
releasing this shocking photo look at
that two small children abandoned along
the rio grande river with a note left on
the infant's carrier identifying them as
siblings from the country of honduras
brandon judd is the president of the
national border patrol council and he
joins us live brandon good morning
it's good to be with you thank you so
you know that that last image it's a
little two-year-old girl and apparently
a three-month-old baby just abandoned by
somebody presumably their parents
but nonetheless
that's heartbreaking
it is and if we didn't have the
resources right there at that time we
wouldn't have encountered those those
two children and when you look at those
seven thousand that are under the bridge
i'm going to tell you it's amazing that
we had the resources you know steve when
i put on a uniform and i go to work
i can tell you every single day it seems
like we have less and less resources
because of those 7 000 people we're
having to pull
resources from other sectors on the
southwest border we're pulling resources
from the northern border from the
coastal borders and and we're making the
we're destabilizing their those borders
as well so instead of the biting
administration looking at this problem
and saying there have been solutions in
the past this isn't rocket science we
can come up with the solution
immediately they continue to pretend
like it's not happening it's like
they're putting their head in the sand
and they're not protecting the innocent
they're not protecting united states
citizens and of course those small
children that if we wouldn't have found
them they would have died right i know
our white house correspondent brought
this up last week in the white house
briefing room where he asked uh
jinsaki okay let me get this straight so
if you have a company with more than a
hundred employees you've got to make
sure that all of your employees are
vaccinated but if you're a migrant
walking across our southern border you
don't need a vaccine right and the
answer was correct well now it turns out
the u.s is going to start requiring all
migrants to a who are going to apply for
residency
to be vaccinated unless brandon they're
crossing illegally which we know they're
doing left and right
yeah exactly you know i can personally
tell you again that when they come in
our custody we don't test them for covid
we don't vaccinate them we just released
them into the united states and so
you know he's requiring united states
citizens to get vaccinated but those
people that are entering our country
illegally they don't have to get
vaccinated they're able to spread that
the disease throughout the united states
again the hypocrisy knows no end with
this administration and you know we
mentioned this about 20 minutes ago
the evacuation flights into
various countries out of afghanistan
have been put on pause for a week
because of an outbreak of measles i mean
you know we've been talking about are
these people properly vetted but then
you wonder whether they're going to be
bringing a disease into another country
and that is the worry about what we're
looking at at our southern border
yeah covet 19 is just one of the
diseases that come into the united
states we see it all the time we take
people into custody all the time that
seem sick we take them to the hospital
and they're they're diagnosed with many
different diseases and that's what's
coming across the border you know it's
not just that they're not uh vaccinated
with covenanting we're looking at
hepatitis we're looking at all kinds of
different diseases that people aren't
being vaccinated for and that's coming
into the united states right now as we
speak well you know what brandon uh the
white house seems to be okay with what's
happening you look at those pictures you
see the kids abandon you see seven
thousand people uh you know sheltering
in place under a bridge until they are
apprehended by the government because
they got to be metered out
this is exact is this exactly what joe
biden wants it to look like because it
looks chaotic to us
for his base this is this is exactly
what they want they want the borders to
be open they want people to flood into
the united states we know that we've
seen that all the time and all you have
to do is look at who's stacked in the
department of homeland security look at
their backgrounds look where they came
look where they come from they're coming
from open borders groups and that's the
problem that we're looking at right now
there is no enforcement right now on the
border and that's why we're seeing these
thousands upon thousands of people
crossing and it's not just that the 7
000 under the bridge we already had more
than 2 000 people in the stations in del
rio that's why we have to meter them out
because we just don't have the capacity
to take these people into custody well
it's a tough job uh and we're glad
you're there but we wish it wasn't this
situation brandon thank you very much
for joining us live today from tucson
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now